[Music]
Kevin Ibanez spends most of his work
life in the jungle the camp lies on a
river on the border between Peru and
Bolivia his office is in the city of
puerto maldonado a whole day's boat ride
away
[Music]
I always loved nature but not only to
see it to admire it I wanted to do
something for it
my favorite color is green and here in
the jungle you can see lots of greens
different greens even this is one of the
most biodiverse areas in all the world
with lots of his species of animals and
plants the focus of Kevin's work is the
yellow-spotted River turtle it's on the
brink of extinction for years
conservationists have been watching
their numbers fall come to the beaches
to regather desex yeah because they eat
them and also they sell it umberto we
have more than 90 percent yeah emptiness
it's a lucrative business the X can be
sold on markets outside the jungle at
high prices but when torture has stopped
eating the turtle eggs but he comes from
the only village in the vicinity so he
knows how to find the nest first we
identify the trail left by the turtle
and then we follow it until we reach the
nest they'll either
the Nature Reserve covers around a
million hectares outside the park wood
cutters and gold prospectors are
devouring their way through the
rainforest endangered species like
parrots seek refuge here
you can feel it everywhere where you go
inside the rainforest you can have the
plants all around you can watch any
animal at any moment when we do our job
we wake up really early go to the forest
do some kind of monitoring for example
and with these results you can make
decisions Kevin and his colleagues from
the National Park want to find out which
animals are in the area and where they
live images from the wildlife cameras
are invaluable the conservationists are
already one step closer to protecting
the turtles they're breeding them here
on this artificial beach judging by the
temperature they're about to hatch
around 700 of them which will then be
put back in their natural habitat
they're trying to prove this the
alternative right to make the population
grow they've had great success with the
cameras
until now we are watching we have seen a
small cut yeah this colmar guy many
dears
really nice pictures of you of deers
tapanade 2-tuples
appears almost all of these animals are
on the red list of endangered species
[Music]
they should all find a good home soon
and the Nature Reserve but the people
who live in the forest need to make
changes to their way of life too
the group meets edwin's family who've
come from the village to fish in the
river they mostly live off the jungle
alongside fish turtle eggs are a major
source of protein they have the
tradition to eat East River turtle eggs
they always have done that even their
grandfathers and even before because
they used to do this today traveling
along the river and River had these
resources we can stop them for this
reason the jungle residents are allowed
to continue eating the eggs but selling
them is now strictly prohibited Kevin
wants to know if the ban is working but
he finds some at the first stall
[Music]
Oh
the woman would have in the equivalent
of 5 euros for a dozen turtle eggs she
doesn't appear to have any qualms here
we could find some River starts Alex
it's a docent this is surreal sad sad
thing right I didn't expected to find
this here in the market the central
market of workers like for squares to
the main square for some time yeah well
what this means that we have to make
more force in the next year's to work
with the people to make to make that is
really beautiful and important species
can go on but as the city grows the
turtles future looks increasingly bleak
the population of puerto maldonado has
been soaring ever since it linked up to
a major highway and as the population
rises so does the pressure on the
rainforest